I've lived in this area my entire life
right on the United States border
just a half a mile across the river from
Detroit
[Music]
I've been a scuba diver and a diving
instructor for over 25 years
I was a broke University student and it
was the only place I could dive
[Music]
because of wind and waves the visibility
is very limited so usually less than
five feet and sometimes as little as one
foot of visibility so when you can only
see this far in front of your face it's
going to limit the people who are
actually going to want to do that dive
there is a very strong current in the
river and it can really drag you down
the river quickly it's an extremely
dangerous environment to say the least
[Music]
I found that every single dive was an
adventure you could find bottles and
cars and boats and shipwrecks and guns
and it just hooked me and I've continued
to do to do it till this day
I was speaking with a local diver
he said he had found a vehicle that was
upside down
laying in the middle of the Detroit
River
and it was something that definitely
should not have been there since this
was not something that was well known I
wanted to follow up and see it for
myself
[Music]
now remember with only a foot of
visibility in the river it's easier said
than done
I do a search pattern so you just do a
zigzag on the bottom of the water just
going back and forth and just seeing
what you can find
you saw coming out of the Gloom
wooden
spokes for a vehicle
that told me this vehicle was very early
at that point I did not know anything
more about the history of it I didn't
know what kind of vehicle it was but I
really wanted to try and find out
a couple more times
and I used my underwater video camera
with a high powered light to really
document and get this evidence together
just so I could try to build a model of
what I was seeing underwater
and what I saw was amazing
[Music]
the vehicle was upside down
it was buried in the sediment so all I
could really see was the bottom part of
the wheels
engine poking out but I really couldn't
see anything more of the top side of the
vehicle
it was a wooden floorboard and there was
a truck bed so very quickly I determined
that this was not a car at all it was
actually a truck
[Music]
lying close to the back was a heavy
chain
we also saw a crank handle on the front
of the vehicle you would actually have
to crank that motor to get it started
so the truck was old enough not to have
an electric starter motor
but what kind of truck was it
[Music]
thank you